[Music]
so let's go 10,000 feet up in the air
and take a look at migrations
alright so migration is a journey and
the journey always starts with a careful
and thorough assessment of the
environments you want to move right and
then you do what we call cloud
foundations cloud foundations we mean
you start a networking preparations you
do identity management project and
organizational structure and so on and
then there's this little task of
actually moving your workloads into GCP
and then you optimize when we say
optimize we mean you can reduce costs
you can improve performance you can
leverage manage services or use cloud
native technologies whatever works so we
talked about assessment Ron mentioned
that's the first one but actually what
we want to enable you with is prior to
the assessment before you start
deploying an assessment tool and
understand what's in the environment
it's really important to understand what
your cloud strategy is so Google's
professional services organization has
released something known as the G calf
which is the Google cloud adoption
framework I recommend everyone download
this it's a white paper and what it does
is it really goes over all the major key
items that you need to focus on as
you're looking to take your cloud
journey everything from culture change
to making sure that everyone has the
right skill sets technologies and really
helping the business define and I
usually say when I work with my
customers I bring this usually to the
c-suite we're able to have you know some
very deep discussions and really at any
level of the organization it really
helps you plan so that when you go into
the assessment phase you're gonna get
what you're looking for and you have the
right strategy from a corporate
standpoint and speaking of assessment
phase let's talk a little bit what's
happening during assessment and
discovery
so there's enablement and training right
GCP is a new platform you might need new
tool sets new skill sets you might want
to do some proof-of-concept you take
inventory of applications workloads
servers licenses
operating systems the works you start
thinking about costs right especially if
he moved from on-prem it's a different
financial model you do some dependency
mappings between the applications and
the workloads and then you start
thinking about how you catalog the
applications and which ones you gotta
move first to the cloud and this is an
example of one way to catalog
applications so we got applications that
are what we call disconnected meaning
they don't have any dependencies and
they're not mission-critical and those
are relatively easy then you got a ones
that have some dependencies but we're
still not mission-critical
like back office gets trickier and any
web production workloads your ERP and
your databases and your production apps
and they're they obviously have cross
dependencies and their mission-critical
and those get hard or sometimes
impossible to move so when you go
through the assessment phase you're
gonna get to learn about the two tools
that we've partnered with we talked
about characteristics of a good first
mover and what I'm gonna do here is I'm
gonna highlight just a few that are
critical so for example a lot of
companies go into this and they say you
know what if we can move our largest
application that's gonna be success and
companies do this I don't recommend it I
usually recommend you choose something
that's not business critical there's
always a lot of risk when you get
started there's a lot of learning
usually on your side and you want to
make sure you do something that really
can be consumed and that you've reduced
risk because then the day you want to
start proving out the clouds the right
move for you that you really understand
how to properly migrate and that's a
good direction to go in
also to highly highlight you don't want
to choose edge cases all right a lot of
customers have that really difficult
application and they'd like to use that
it's not good and here's why when you do
the first migrations you want to do
something that's repeatable because
everyone the organization's gonna be
doing this for the first time so you
want an application that's very
representative of what may be a majority
or a good percentage of your
applications are some other wants to
really focus on I would say are
requiring less app refactoring and
less data migration because you want to
get a quick win you want to get
comfortable at the cloud through one of
our tools Bella strata when you talk
about having a lot of data you don't
have to worry about it because the VM
comes up in Google cloud as it streams
the data but still nonetheless choose
something with a small enough data sets
you can really get that win quicker than
not and the last one just to highlight
is compliance challenges so I personally
have been in situations where a customer
says we have the perfect app everyone
goes forward and then compliance comes
in says this one's highly regulated and
it takes about eight months to work
their compliance so these are the kinds
of questions you want to ask internally
as you're working and also as you work
with the Google partner so how do we
make this happen well we have for
migration partners cloud physics strata
zone both of who are here today and also
risk networks and cloud amaz and this is
really going to give you the tools to
understand deeply what's in your
environment from a cost perspective and
also from a component perspective as
well as connectivity between those
components so with that being said I'd
like to introduce Chris grosse Meyer
from cloud physics so called physics is
really the first step when you get to
that level of assessment that you want
to make that decision to go to the cloud
or not go to the cloud at some point
you're gonna have to have a marker and
indicator telling you is this an
opportunity so when we look at the
ecosystems of users out there the
platform's a little bit more broad IT
users use this day-to-day our pedigree
started as a vSphere administrative tool
great insights into what's going on in
the virtual infrastructure a lot of
analytics and sprite sizing and
functionality really giving you
meaningful use as a vSphere admin in the
data center if you're a channel partner
this is really the next level up that
we're seeing a lot of activity this is
that trusted advisor the team or the
partner that's coming in and helping you
make that intelligent decision to go to
the cloud they come in they may offer
the assessment for you be fully funded
they may offer hardware refresh
right-sizing and other services to help
you get there they're really critical to
making sure that that happens and again
like I said that trusted advisor and
that collaborative intelligence of you
between the two of you and ultimately
this third tier also Google Intel
funding these types of assessments and
helping you guys make the right move
reference architectures best practices
showing services that have been
repeatable and usable in
past combined these are all the channel
partners and the resources that are sure
bringing these types of assessments to
market so you don't have to feel like
you're doing this alone so we have
multiple use cases I'm going to talk to
you real quick here getting a view of
what's going on inside my datacenter is
the first part the platform but what's
nice is once we have performance data
and configuration data we can start
doing costing and modeling one of the
core functionalities of the platform
allows us to model approximate costs of
resources and estimates of how much is
our data center cost to operate today an
intelligent meaning of that value is
that we can look at it and say is it
going to save us money or cost us more
so this ROI and TCO type analysis
getting visibility into what's unique
about on-premise the hardware the
resources were consuming services and
power and things like that on the cloud
side though changing up the region's
changing storage options changing sizing
options and right sizing choosing
different geographies we can apply all
those different costs and give you
approximations between the two resources
as well as other clouds if that were so
being in the assessment and ignore the
bullets here I'll talk to the image
looks like they get out of sync here for
those of you that have premise
on-premise Hardware visibility into the
hardware and the resources is also going
to be critical as you start aging out
your old systems you're running vSphere
6 that Oh Oh or maybe 5.5 you want to
make that migration to vSphere 6.7
there's going to be an opportunity to do
some hardware refresh potentially and
what you really want to start is looking
at the story that's relevant to this
cloud migration should I replace this
hardware and bring it up to 6 at 7 and
invest those resources or is there a
cost avoidance by moving to the cloud
and having the intelligence behind the
scenes as to the number of resources and
what potentially should move is going to
be important that one that sort of auto
order here that show migration to AWS
scenario we can actually pull in the
live feed from that ec2 cloud watch your
billing resources and start looking at
the cost and the spend on AWS and give
you a comparative compare comparison of
resources on GCP looking at the
instances identifying which would be the
ideal class maybe we want to do some
right sizing and adjust based on
performance taking some of the waste
that we have on the other clouds
we've seen typically a resource that's
deployed once it's out there it's very
rarely adjusted or right-sized
taking those types of intelligence and
making that compelling story internally
for that cloud migration and finally
some financial and performance analysis
there's a lot more inside the data
center that may have an impact on their
decision to move storage for example
storage wasted resources and hardware
refresh licenses and third-party
resources in the data center how
efficiently is your team actually
managing the data as well you know like
I said our pedigree started off as a
vSphere admin tool a lot of the best
practices and resources patching and
management gaining that visibility and
understanding how efficiently you
actually manage your data center may be
important you may find that you are
doing a excellent job and you can
actually keep things on premise very
efficiently while you do the migration
or you may find that you are way behind
the times you're not doing support
you're not doing updates there's a lot
of security issues out there maybe it's
time to move to the cloud and let the
cloud providers take on that that risk
for you
sar contextually quickly address how
this kind of works club physics is and
appliance we're a single virtual
appliance purview center or a connection
into the cloud provider and what we'll
do is we'll collect performance and
configuration metadata from the
resources and bring it to the cloud for
analysis so we are a SAS based platform
we will continue to collect that data at
the most granular level as possible to
us so for the virtual infrastructure
every 20 seconds that 20-second
granularity is great because we can do a
lot of histograms and detailed analysis
on that as well as the configuration
data we have a shared portal view of it
as well so once it comes down the
partners and you can work together and
collaborate on that data and we're very
non-intrusive
the only thing we need to talk to in the
virtual environment is resources like
the managers like a V Center we do not
have to touch the hosts we do not have
touched a guest we are not using an
agent everything we do is through
directly through the VMware API s and
they actually do the resource collection
for us so no extra load on the
infrastructure and pulling that data in
since we are only looking predominantly
a metadata performance configuration we
don't have to look into the operating
system there's no reason to go in there
unless you're doing an application
discovery and application dependency
that would be the only reason you'd set
up it but if you're in a high security
or highly
environment we can restrict that access
and just let the appliance do its
activity takes about five minutes to
deploy it's quick and easy to get going
once it's up and running we have data in
the portal within 15 minutes like I said
we collect that data on that 20-second
granularity and we let it keep running
so the duration of your assessment so if
you're doing an assessment today
tomorrow for seven days we see the highs
and lows over the course of that week we
know what the weekend activity is nice
thing is this appliance can keep running
forever you can use the platform in the
portal has a vSphere administrative tool
you can stage your migrations over time
look at trends and usage activity Peaks
99th and 95th percentile means and
averages of utilization of all the
resources as well
architectural e the data that we're
collecting predominantly is
configuration data for all the resources
in the data center network storage
compute your clusters and hosts and the
details that are there as well in the
VMS and we collect the performance
metadata CPU memory bandwidth storage
i/o utilizations we do this for both
on-premise and for the cloud side of the
activity now it's great because once we
have this data we can look at
configurations and make recommendations
for moving resources from cloud to cloud
very quickly and we can also look at
right sizing and performance
characteristics
maybe this resource would be better off
and something else maybe we can
consolidate multiple easy resources down
to a single entity reducing the number
of instances in the cloud all that data
is coming into us comes into that 20
second granularity for the virtual
environment everything that we're
bringing in is encrypted to us
it's D&E and not or sorry anonymized SE
d anonymize but it's anonymized to us so
all we're looking at is just an organ
identifier and performance metadata no
CPU try yeah no IP addresses and MAC
addresses specific to most the
assessments unless that's something you
want to enable now for the demo side of
it I'm gonna tell you a little bit what
we're gonna do we're gonna go through
we're gonna by default the partners
usually have invited a customer into the
platform already so that first step you
will actually receive an email you log
into the portal and the first activity
you would do is deploy our observer it's
very quick it's a download as an o VAR o
VF powers it up or set up the
connections into your cloud if you want
to add other users ask
all right the assessments in the
platform there's hundreds and hundreds
of analytics we categorize these things
into assessments and assessments in this
case this is the GCP and Intel
assessment they've gone through and
chose what characteristics that were
meaningful for them to put into this
review so as a platform there's a free
edition and there's a premium edition
but in the terms of the assessments all
the analytics are related to the
assessment are provided and funded by
Google and Intel what we're gonna have
here is in terms of the analytics are
individual reports these are what we
break out into our cards cards like
vCenter summary actually giving us a
collaborative view of what resources are
currently in our data center host
analysis what hardware's end-of-life
what should be refreshed as well as
guest operating systems really this
really gives us a foundation as that
trusted advisor as a partner or for
Google to see the resources and make a
recommendation as we go I'm gonna start
here with sort of that Universal view
and before we actually make the
migration the cloud it's worth noting
what do we have are we looking at one
cluster multiple data centers multiple
campuses multiple networks and resources
this is really more so for everybody to
get into agreement as to what resources
are out here really just set the tone of
did we actually go and look at the right
environment back us up host analysis
offers two functionalities for us give
us an idea of the resources that you
have and how you've deployed them see
the hardware we can identify resources
that potentially could be end-of-life
like we talked about this opportunity to
go through and say you know what I've
got a large number of servers in my
datacenter but I'm considering whether
and I should go 26.7 so let's do a quick
look in the infrastructure and find out
how many hosts are not compatible with
vSphere 6.7 or 6.5 in this case and I
see in this organization there are 46
hosts out there that are not compatible
with that the release of the hypervisor
now this is a inflection point for us do
we decide to replace the hardware and
upgrade and buy new hypervisor licenses
or is this really the opportunity for us
to move those infrastructure that
infrastructure to the cloud so as this
works as a narrative for us we'll go
through and build this up stepping back
there we go guest operating an Alice
guest operating-system analysis really
is the on premise workload so and we're
looking at either the cloud or we're
looking at the virtual infrastructure
these are the resources that you
currently have inside the infrastructure
that are virtualized and deployed we see
them as they're configured the resources
are consuming we see the age an end of
life for some of these operating systems
so maybe there's opportunity to move
some of this to new version windows for
example hi as well as what aren't going
to be candidates for cloud migration
we're going to see things in here like
ESX vSphere running as the nested vm
maybe we see the Mac OS we'll go through
and clarify and identify resources that
are not going to be cloud candidates now
most organizations need to start working
on a workflow and managing the content
so we break this out to some degree
based on all the metrics that are
important to you whether it be clusters
or hosts or organizations or logical
containers and resources data stores
security groups state OS family and such
as well as the ability to go through and
tag these individually so I may want to
take a subset of these as production
staging DevOps we do some automatic
tagging through the infrastructure will
pull tags from vCenter if they already
exist if you are doing application
collection will apply the application
identity for that VM and start doing
some application based tagging as well
as guest processes so if you are looking
at certain resources inside of the
resources as well now we can use this to
tag and manage and down to a minimum
subset of resources that might want to
move to the cloud so we can tag
individually and see multiple tags I
have a couple of them already out here
and we're gonna use that in just a
second I forgot which monitor is easier
to see ultimately before we make the
cloud migration there's a there's a
portion of this that is quick costing I
want to do a quick estimate to find out
whether this is a no-go or no-go the
effort to go through and identify
hardware and services resources in the
data center quantify up early and figure
out is there an opportunity for me to
move these resources takes two parts
what does it cost me on-premise and what
it's going to cost me the cloud we do
some on-premise cost simulations there's
a lot of attributes that you can go
through and tune through this as well
but the top level ones
cost of hardware cost of storage cost to
memory cost of Licensing and support
cost of third-party services as well as
staffing and resources like that or
power and cooling lots of attributes and
variables we'll go through and touch on
but what's nice is we quantify a total
cost of the data center will actually
take those and apply that to every one
of the workloads and the end result is
for each workload we'll sort of quantify
as a percentage of the entire data set
what is it using in terms of storage and
compute memory and we'll give you a cost
per workload as it is configured let's
see if I can get my mouse on top of that
I can't see from my angle there we go
cost of storage cost to compute giving
an overview we do some right sizing when
we talk about some cost avoidance and
some summary details of the
infrastructure now what's nice is that
we have all the metrics and all the data
is collected from the infrastructure all
the I ops all the throughputs all the
contentions all that data is known for
us behind the scenes so we can actually
go and do exports and CSV and
derivatives were views of other cards to
actually give you some more information
on your migration once we've got our
cost the second part is what's our cloud
our cloud cost costing for the clouds a
little bit easier
choosing a geography choosing whether we
want pre-emptive if we want reserved
instances do we want a one-year two-year
commit three-year commit storage and
geography are going to be the easy ones
but the one that throws people off is
this idea of right sizing obviously
every application orders going to ask
for as many resources as possible saying
it's 64 CPUs and a terabyte of RAM
they're gonna ask for it whether they
need it or not but ultimately what we're
gonna see is what was the actual
utilization
where did they peak out in terms of
their actual utilization day to day and
was there an opportunity for right
sizing that how do they perform 99
percent of the time or 95th percentile
and using those as guidelines because we
may see a peak out there at a hundred
percent but it may be very short-lived
it could have been a Windows reboot an
update maybe it was the backup window or
something happening inside the OS so
going through and letting you drill in
and looking at actual metrics for
individual resources are available to us
we can go look at per hour per second
see the type of activity that we have
had during the day in this case a single
VM here
can't see that's hidden here how many
CPUs that was CPU and performance two
CPUs used one one-and-a-half CPUs with a
performance at its peak you know do we
write size fat level knowing that that
was a one-time event or was it something
that happened over the course of the day
multiple times and as we start looking
over the course of a week or a month and
get into lots of detail we see that you
know that short-lived spike is very
short-lived universally it's not
something that we're worrying about for
our day-to-day production as we've gone
through the platform we've gone through
and seen the resources we've seen the
hosts we've seen the VMS there's that
pricing for GCP we quantified what the
cost was we can also take that live data
from the cloud providers AWS feed it
into the platform and give you that AWS
to GCP migration opportunity as well
with the right sizing the performance
and the analytics and the cost knowing
that a resource was a 3x large on AWS
ends up being a custom sized resource on
GC p and will tell you specifically what
the customization would be we'll do the
direct matching our analytics that comes
in for the matching we actually update
from the api's directly from google
everyday so we'll match out all the
current instances and geographies and
costs so we'll model that resources for
you as well as showing you that option
even for GCP maybe giving you the option
to cut some costs by right sizing down
to that 99th percentile taking several
hundred thousand dollars out of your
monthly or annual bill now again this is
one for one type activity we do offer a
complete view if you have multiple
clouds in your assessment the ability to
go through and look at what would be the
cost for choosing the same geography
same storage changing different
configurations or attributes what will
it be for those different clouds Azure
and hyper-v AWS GCP or on-prem where is
my advantage going to be in my cloud
migration now some clarification here we
are looking at the entire data set what
you really want to do is focus in on a
per migration or per resource level and
go through and take those attributes and
make an intelligent decision so we
talked about resources that we may have
take Turley err
I have resources our candidates and just
looking at my subset of resources out
there these are really the only
candidates I tagged as a whole saving
money from as configured down to that
right sizing taking some slack how the
environment saving us additional three
hundred thousand through that process
for the rest of us if we're not very
technical you're in the sales or you're
in a management position you potentially
are going to come in and say you know
that was all great and dandy but I have
a architect team to do that I just want
the output we'll go through and actually
generate the reports for that as well
actually when I am I skipped here
AWS billing visibility if you do keep
content in AWS and you want to go look
at the costing today will show you the
exact cost of the resources that you're
consuming for bandwidth inbound outbound
snapshots all the sub items there and
then as well
comparison into GCP but take a time here
Wizards for those of you that aren't
familiar with the cards and I want to
get too much detail into it will guide
you through the Wizards and generate out
those reports again the type of thing
that management really wants as a
baseline the type of things that you
typically do for a larger service these
are available to you very quickly
without ever having to have a consultant
on site or service engagement if you've
done the deployment of the appliance
this type of visibility is going to come
back to you allowing you to have the
results here within a few days
ultimately we recommend going this the
full week we want to see the peaks we
want to see weekends we can run it
longer full month and what's nice is the
cloud physics observer can be left in
the organization and you can run this
weekly monthly quarterly and do an
annual comparison as you've gone through
that migration effort costing out what's
on premise costing out what's in the
cloud and with that I'm gonna pass over
to Carl so we're gonna talk a little bit
almost as we follow through from where
Chris left off we're gonna talk a little
bit about stratas own the platform
itself what it helps you do so strata
zone is a purpose-built born in cloud
platform designed entirely to take your
risk and help you overcome challenges in
the cloud migration space or in the
process of planning your migration as an
organization as well as executing on
your migrations so
as we go through this one of the things
you'll see that minimizing risk is a big
thing for us right so what are what are
the biggest risks in the cloud migration
space one of the risks one of the risks
is around not knowing your environment
so environment discovery is super
important very scalable environment
discovery helps you get through
thousands of workloads in a very short
period of time and most importantly from
there what its gonna let you do is
actually map those workloads globally on
a global sync if you've got data centers
in multiple locations you've got data
centers in multiple countries it doesn't
matter pull everything together and the
other big risk that customers face today
is around the requirements your risks
around your requirements stem from the
fact that a cloud strategy has to be
based on your CFO's priorities your
organization's priorities and most
importantly your best way to get the
return on investment from from a cloud
strategy you know when you put those two
things two things together one of the
things that we do as a platform is we're
gonna get your consumption velocity
moved up and why do you need your
consumption velocity moved up one of the
biggest challenges we've seen over
thousands and thousands of workloads
being moved to the cloud is that when
you're straddling both sides of the
fence you're still part private and you
slow down in your consumption into cloud
you are going to end up with an extra
cost because you're straddling both
sides your resources have to be doubled
up your your facilities have to be
doubled up you can't exactly shut down a
data center so your footprint still
remains out there power cooling so on
and so forth so there's a lot around the
risk factors that that you have to take
into consideration so our entire goal is
to help you accelerate that consumption
cycle so most importantly what stradun
does outside of the risk mitigation is
getting you to understand what goes
where and when once you get that you can
put a road map together very easily the
challenge in getting there is is if you
don't have that that roadmap of what we
call a consumable roadmap it has to be
realistic and consumable it's the
biggest missing piece in most customers
cloud planning so once you get a
consumable roadmap that's what goes
where and when what is the delivery
model one of my pin
zooming with platform-as-a-service what
am i consuming with with
infrastructure-as-a-service
what stays private what can move to
cloud right so basically we call that
the delivery model how you gonna deliver
cloud to your organization and the
implementation model are you going to
implement cloud across all your assets
are you gonna stay with just a few
assets that'll end up going into the
cloud right so really having a good grip
on that is the biggest priority for most
of our customers now of course the
platform will pick for you the best fit
products and then we address the largest
risk area is the return on investment
actually going to be there am I actually
saving money going to cloud the platform
will pick the products for you it'll
load it for you and most importantly
it's going to give you probably the most
powerful pricing engine to go and look
at cloud products compare them to a
private data center benchmarks and make
sure that you're actually saving money
going into cloud not every use case may
work for you and those use cases that do
work for you you have to be able to
justify that up and sideways in the
organization so what do we do for you
there in the TCO ROI in the financial
space we have a benchmark private data
center its certified it avoids you
having to pick your own cost for the
organization and go find your costs if
you do want to bring your own cost to
the table we can incorporate those and
you'll have your own customer data
center which is customized but either
way we need a left site to compare the
right side to right we need your private
data center costs in order to compare
that to the cloud so when you start
looking at how detailed you get in there
we fundamentally can produce the level
of CFO business case for you that lets
you go up in the organization and make
the justification to move to cloud now a
lot of times people say it's a
no-brainer push a couple of buttons you
get there when you start talking to your
c-suite and your CFO the level of detail
they want is a lot more complicated so
our business cases handle things like
depreciation cycles you know fixed costs
sunk cost so on and so forth so just
being prepared with that is important
and then the other like I said the big
important thing here about about making
sure you know what you're doing is a
consumable roadmap that consumable
roadmap has to have small enough pieces
that can be executed and can be executed
in a successful manner as tad was saying
earlier you want to pick success stories
and then build on those success stories
as your organization morphs into clout
and that's what the consumable roadmap
is designed to do start out with small
successes and move to the next steps and
then the last thing here a predictable
migration cost that's one of the biggest
shortcomings of cloud migration plans
planning is great when you go to migrate
you don't know what those costs are and
it can mess up your your return on
investment and then at that point your
accountabilities sort of questioned
around the whole strategy so on a
technical level for those who are
technical here you know this is a 10,000
foot view inventory analysis down to the
performance capacity percentiles all the
usual things you'd expect that anybody
would require in order to make a good
sound decision and how you're going to
consume cloud requirements definition
most importantly cloud fed analysis a
very quick ability to see what's a good
fit for cloud what's not a good fit what
your remediation requirements are and
how much work you're going to have to do
to get those workloads or those
applications into the cloud right
application mapping and dependency
mapping two of the most important risk
areas that everybody runs into not
necessarily on day one but down the road
so that's one of the other capabilities
around the platform is to be able to do
very accurate application and dependency
mapping and one of the big ones I like
to point out over thousands and
thousands of workloads we found out that
about 32% of our customers assets are
essentially being kept on or the lights
are on for the purposes of of archived
customers don't know what to do with it
they can get rid of it so data estate
analysis lets you take those expensive
archive archive type assets and put
those into cold or warm storage which is
probably about we calculator out 50th of
the cost of running a data center space
to keep those keep that data in place
wait so one of the things we've done as
well we looked at the speed to which the
strata zone platform helps you get get
to your decisioning points our business
case runs about three to five days once
you do data discovery we'll talk about
that in a second and our entire plan is
usually done in about four to five weeks
that is all the way to what's called a
trigger ready state including
application mapping and all of the
pieces that go with that including a
migration run book that you would need
in order to get from point A to point B
so how do you get started again to a
pointer from earlier google has licensed
the platform so it's available to
customers for free you fill up a form
the form asks you to tell us about your
data center environments those
environments are important because we'd
like to know how you want your data
rolled up so once you fill in that form
it'll work flow to you a series of data
collectors that are uniquely numbered
and tagged and what those data
collectors do is that they report into
the platform with the way you want to
see your data so it could be amia you
know north america
data center one data center - it doesn't
matter we pre tag data it's very
important for us they're very important
for you because the level of automation
gives you reports starting the next
morning wait you're gonna start seeing
reports come in and we'd like to see
them tagged the way you want to see them
so 30 minutes to install the data
collector you can start looking at
results in a couple hours we like to do
at least one day of data polls the
longer you let her run the better the
data looks right and the most important
thing here is that let's say your
retailer and you have something that you
want to check in November or you have an
end of month process you can schedule
the data collectors to kick off again at
the end of the month or end of the week
or whenever that whenever that peak
anticipated peak period is gonna be so
that is the extent of the work you do to
start doing an assessment in your
environment right it's 30 minutes per
collector you install it you let it run
after that you're pretty much working on
all your data and getting all of the
advance deliverables that we can produce
for you so what I'd like to do is talk a
little bit for a second about security
it is a SAS platform all of the data
we're collecting is entirely metadata
related it's not application data and
not user data nothing that falls under
any regulatory requirements so there's
no issues around you know hippo or
anything from that perspective and most
importantly we have that conversation
with your CISOs your security folks if
they want to ask questions there's a
security white paper that's available to
them talks about every field we collect
and what's really neat is that they can
inspect the actual JSON files before
they're transmitted into their portal so
you can see every single field we're
collecting and validate that what we
said we're collecting is what you're
seeing being transmitted and
everything's encrypted in transit
encrypt that arrest all the usuals
things that you would typically expect
but on top of all of that what
we have is the ability to custom
anonymize so if a specific customer says
I don't want my IP addresses going into
your cloud yeah you're 180 to arrange
the same as one 180 to arrange but let's
say you don't want it in the cloud you
can actually select the degree of
anonymization that you'd like to see in
the platform right so you can go all the
way to every piece of identifiable data
being removed or you can just have a
couple things removed rarely happens but
the features and capabilities are there
so last but not least once you've done
all that great planning Stratus on as a
platform goes from end to end we're
gonna help you with your your your
business case your data analysis we're
going to help you put all of your plan
together build roadmaps and we'll talk
about roadmaps in a second once you've
built all of that you really need to
leverage that in your migration plan one
of the biggest downfalls of of migration
plans is that a great plan was done but
then the migration plan ends up being
done by a different team different party
and it's completely different so here we
actually carry all of your planning and
leverage your investment in the previous
work you did into the actual migration
process and we integrate with Miele
strata for GCP and it'll automatically
put build that run book for you and
actually move the assets into GCP when
you're looking at doing a VM migration
so it's a very smooth process you get a
single pane of glass to control your
entire migration process and what
happens there is that the business units
that you work with are also you know at
the end of the day their process becomes
smoother and so they're they're more
likely to participate when you can show
them that you have an organized way of
getting their assets migrated into the
cloud here's a quick example of a
process we went through our partner
maven wave customer harmony started data
collection of our roughly 3,000 assets
on a Friday the whole business case was
ready presented on on a Wednesday right
so you've got a lot of analytics that go
around the business case and you can get
to see all of those details from
dependency mapping the business case at
the executive level the fully loaded TCO
ROI so it really is not just they
compute storage and memory kind of
business case it is a fully loaded
business case including the cost of
transition and and that's what the
platform will produce in literally 24
hours to three days depending on how
long you want you
let the data run so this one we're going
to jump into the platform real quick and
do a and do a demo so Stratus one is a
platform is let me reduce that it's a
SAS platform what you see as a customer
is what your partner see and is also
what your deployment folks see it's it's
completely transparent pricing engine is
completely transparent everything's
available to you kicking off in
assessments very easy it's basically a
quick form that you kick off once you
get access you do an automated asset
discovery and all we need is who we're
gonna email that one to right so
assessments in general you can have
multiple assessments globally you can
pull all this data together it does all
of that global thing for you but we'd
like to know where your data is coming
from that's why you see multiple
assessments globally in multiple
locations once you deploy those data
collectors that's the end of any work
you do as a customer or as a partner
everything comes into the platform it's
maintained here and you can you can sort
and filter through your different areas
but most importantly what we're
capturing this module by the way runs
entirely on its own what we're capturing
for you is we're getting all of your
performance stats we're profiling your
assets if you notice as they come in
you'll see here you've got all of your
your I ops and your in your performance
metrics everything that's important to
you to to do your right sizing and your
pricing and we'll talk about that in a
second but our optimization engine is
extremely sophisticated we call it the
truth serum a lot of our customers will
go to cloud and they'll come back and
say I use the TCO calculator clouds more
expensive than my data center once they
go through this platform we've
challenged every assumption and we've
fed them a very realistic data center
cost from our benchmark data center and
we can actually prove a very very solid
business case around it so again all
your data is coming in all those things
you see on the Left the usual suspects
CPU utilization memory utilization all
that's coming to the platform we've
processed your dependencies but more
importantly at this early stage these
are day 2 reports by the way at this
early stage you can come in here and see
what gets a high medium and a low
scoring for the cloud and your first
question is gonna be well why did I get
a high medium or a low and it it
actually creates your remediation plan
and shows you with with multiple
reasons like your credit report why you
got a high medium or low right so if you
if you look through this process every
single thing has been scored for you
automatically and you can actually give
the system some priorities and say this
is important to me that's not important
to me it's not a point that I'm able to
exit the cloud or I don't want my high
performance compute assets going to the
cloud so once you do this you're a
scoring actually changes but the whole
idea here is based on your priorities
we're giving you a very very solid
machine based score that shows you with
the underlying reasons why you're a good
fit for the cloud or you're not and at
this point there's lots of reports
available this is what we call our day -
our day - reports you've got all your
detailed reports that the data center
folks would like there's a bunch of
executive reports but you can actually
come in here
the platform's automatically right-sized
you and done all the optimization you
can come in here pick your different
locations and generate a ROI calculation
right off the bat basically an ROI a
savings calculation and you can pick one
or more product catalogs that you want
to see it from now typically we make the
other catalogs available in the Google
ecosystem so you want it you want to
actually see what your comparative cost
looks like right but it's it's all real
time catalogs and they will present you
with the results that you can actually
take to your leadership and walk the
cloud plan around and to show you really
quick what that cloud plan looks like it
is going to be a executive level
presentation that talks about what we
did for the assessment where we looked
at at a high level and what we found
I'll skip right to the bottom line
ultimately it's going to get down to an
explanation of how we did your financial
costing in a business case to start the
conversation about moving to cloud this
is available the next morning right we'd
like to have 24 hours of data where you
can pull it in three hours but it's
available in next morning so you've got
a business case you've got a very solid
determination and this is based on
reality data underlying this performance
capacity and an actual real-time catalog
comparison so from here I'd like to show
you a little bit more sophisticated
functionality we won't hit too much on
it I've got four minutes left so one of
the big things here we have a very very
sophisticated approach to doing machine
shaping and that is your your paradigm
today of buying
hardware and in you know resourcing a
data center is based on capacity the
paradigm in the futures based on
elasticity right
you you've got the ability to scale up
and down as you see fit so you need to
change how you you're gonna think again
speaking of the truth serum once we go
through this you're gonna be able to
take out all of the inefficiency in your
current environment and then see what
your real cloud costs are going to be
that's that's really important because
if you don't want the one match you're
simply taking your inefficiency into the
cloud right so this this machine shaping
panel we do it a lot of the GCP
ecosystem partners will do it for you
but ultimately it's going to let you
shape your life in the cloud very
important from here you'll see that the
pricing engine will give you the ability
to go through and really do some
detailed analysis right so if you're
looking here on the different pricing
engines I'm gonna be able to go in and
see exactly what it picked for me and
how it meters to what I have on Prem
today and it's full disclosure so you're
gonna see every single costing factor
that built up that pricing including how
many hours were buying for you if it's
an on-demand catalog and you've got the
ability to look at the the committed
used catalogs it's got all the sustained
use capabilities built in all the
discounting is built in you can get
custom discounting if your large
customer that needs it but at the end of
the day you you're able to come in here
and do a very realistic assessment of
what your world looks like from
comparing the private data center
benchmark or your data into any of the
GCP catalogs for example to see your
savings right very quick and this is
based on actual real information from
your assets under underlying the
platform and then here you'll see one of
the most important things customers
really like about the platform it is
gives you the ability to go in and look
at your dependency maps its processed
your dependencies for you it's gonna
throw these dependencies up on a screen
it's cleaning them for you staking out
the data center noise and when I blow
this up you'll see that it's actually
telling you how all your assets
communicate with each other right
this is cleansed so it's taking out your
ad DNS noise all this stuff that's your
usual monitoring stuff from your data
center and what it's got for you is a
very clean dependency map this is a
business service somehow tied together
so you cannot break this map when you
might
great this is the biggest risk area in
in a customer transition to cloud how am
I gonna break my dependencies I don't
even know my dependencies so first
understanding your dependencies knowing
what you're doing with them and seeing
whether or not you're gonna break those
dependencies and at the end of the cycle
you're able to build out our roadmap the
roadmap is probably the most important
thing here we will deliver a consumable
cloud roadmap what that means it's gonna
have multiple roadmap some multiple
waves and you can come in here and say
pretty much anything you want to the
platform you can come in here and say
show me everything that's the dev
version of my ERP application that has
an asset age over so many years right
and by the way belongs on a certain
subject and it has a server role of dev
or anything you want you say show me my
Windows 2003 that's going to go into a
end-of-life wave so once you build your
roadmap you can figure out how to empty
out that entire data center and actually
get to you can move things around to get
to that return on investment the way you
want to see it from a financial
perspective and not make this a data
center exercise so with that I'll stop
here and pass the mic back so in closing
how do we how does Google actually help
you succeed and most importantly at no
additional cost and this was mentioned
so through our partnership through cloud
physics and Stratis own you can actually
partner with us and we will pay for this
assessment so cloud physics and Stratus
own can actually deliver it on-site you
can do it yourselves you can leverage
one of our partners but the licensing is
fully covered by Google so you can
actually get started right away getting
visibility into your environment making
a strong business case sometimes it's
not even that sometimes it's just
verifying the business case to see if
what you did previously is the right way
to go and one of the great parts that
was mentioned too is allowing these
tools to run when I was a customer I
would let these tools run you know
sometimes around I'd say and a month
we're running our quarterly reports and
it really helped a lot with our capacity
planning so it's more than just right
now it's also in the future to have
these tools running giving you the right
visibility so in closing I'd like to say
it's easy as one two three but that
being said is remember we talked about
the GAF first which is a Google clouds
adoption framework it's a white paper I
recommend everyone download that to take
a look and have a talk within your
company about these things you're gonna
get a solid under
standing of where you currently are and
also the action items that are going to
be needed for next steps to migrate to
the cloud or really to any environment
as you move forward on your journey
after you understand the GK if you have
your strategy in place then engage
Google Engage Stratus own cloud physics
let us come in help you with a no-cost
assessment leveraging these
best-of-breed tools to really get you
the insight you need and then finally
you actually can leverage that insight
to deploy and to migrate so as you might
have seen the products directly
integrate with Vella strata which is our
migration tool so you can go from
understanding your ROI TCO to putting
together move groups understanding how
everything's connected
and then ingesting that directly into
the migration tool to get into Google
cloud and then from there you can
optimize maybe go into kubernetes and
take it to the next level
[Music]